du plomb à l'amiante des résidus de
radioactivité à la malbouffe autant de
danger autant d'étapes pour les cobayes
les lanceurs d'alert ajoute maintenant
le chlordécone
depuis le débat sur le glyphosate les
pouvoirs publics ont démontré qu'ils
pouvaient avoir la mémoire courte
le combat du chlordécone sera là pour le
rappeler on retrouve tout à fait les
mêmes ingrédients quand on a d'autres
scandales sanitaires toujours l'omerta
le manque de transparence et on voit
toujours que l'on met en avant l'
économique et non pas la santé et voyez
moi en tant que députée européenne je me
dis mais c'est inadmissible pour moi
c'est un crime d'état pour l'avocat à
l'origine de la première plainte contre
l'empoisonnement au chlordécone c'était
en 2006 porté le combat à paris voir à
bruxelles
c'est aussi faire avancer la cause le
fait qu'aujourd'hui que nous nous
inscrivions dans une marche plus globale
contre les pesticides contre la force
des lobbys ça nous apporte un certain
réconfort une certaine solidarité qui va
jouer parce que ce qui s'est passé en
guadeloupe continue à se produire
donc quand j'en vois pas avec quelle
force michèle rivasi et younousse
omarjee font entendre la voix de
l'outre-mer dans l'hémicycle en europe
eh bien on se dit que effectivement on
est parfois mieux défendus par l'autre
que par nous-mêmes
la mobilisation ne s'arrêtera pas là les
eurodéputés demandent déjà une enquête
parlementaire